[Music]
I got something for us today you might
as well be dead at that point I got
something for us today
yeah yeah here you go
dude
[Music]
[Music]
that's right Michael Strahan one of our
favorites I am very excited again I am
obsessed okay with Michael Strahan so
Michael Strahan
was on
the Jimmy Fallon show
um
oh this is the biggest shills ever in
one room
this is right after he came back from
space
[Applause]
okay not fair enough this is Strahan
just got that space Jimmy Fallon came
straight into work after being at a
nightclub called space all night that's
right that's how he broke his finger by
the way
Erica's retired and uh that is big
that's big enough news uh to talk about
but then you announced it that you're
going to space going to space man
oh right before I went to space this
blue origin
you're going to space I'm going to space
December 9th and I'm glad you gave me a
joke from your monologue actually that
you didn't use I would never I would
never use it but I wanted to give it to
you just yeah you gave it to me so I
want y'all mind if I read what he was
going to say wow you guys are just this
is what this is what is this what I
don't really watch late night TV
obviously is this what it is oh yeah no
and honestly Fallon's like one of the
less like unpleasant ones to watch hear
me out
Michael Strahan takes over for Fallon
they're probably grooming them for some
kind of night gig
here we go
now when you Google straight hand in
space you don't just get a picture of
your smile
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know what so I I Google I Google of
Jimmy Fallon in space you know what came
up what virgin
what does that mean
Jimmy Fallon's joke as bad as it was but
what does that even mean no no Jimmy
Fallon's joke as bad as it was made
sense as a dad joke right the space in
his teeth
the joke should have been I Googled
Jimmy Fallon in space hey what came back
[ __ ]
okay
I don't know if that would have went
over too well with that audience
although with Michael Strahan saying am
I got away with it yeah
also it makes no sense because Jimmy
Fallon is a notorious poonhound no he is
he actually is like he is pulled more
[ __ ] in New York than probably low-key
like he's not a big uh uh you know he's
like a Seth MacFarlane he just low-key
bangs all his broads yeah really makes
any announcements or anything
and of course her dime pieces Papa
talk to me about this talk to me about
blue how do you do how do you team up
with Bezos what is going on what does
your well I was told that there was an
international organization of
businessmen and they said if I wanted
that job on The Late Night show I'm
gonna have to go space
so basically how did we become so what
happened was we had this thing called
covet right and uh so people like Jeff
Bezos had like billions or more dollars
to spend on Advertising so they
basically like them and like father and
all these people they basically just
bought our show so we're basically like
just a big infomercial now in the
morning let's be honest Jimmy it could
be worth I could have been doing
commercials for FTX that Brady does
I mean clearly you could tell I ain't
got no CTE and I'm making good money I
made it better than most of these broke
[ __ ] NFL especially that [ __ ]
Lawrence Taylor
but for real like you know Michael
Strahan think about it because he's also
from that era of football where he
should be [ __ ] brain dead because his
job was one of those guys to hit people
with his very hard skull repeatedly for
years he should be completely brain dead
and doing local car commercials so he's
probably just grateful to be like I
could still you know put my tie on the
morning my hands don't shake
you know and I make pretty good money
and I got a nice quiet life I don't
really mind it too much you know they
told me I could play three more years
but I know as dumb as I sound
it really isn't it sounds dumb because
of his Liz but he's really not an idiot
he's that Herschel Walker who's still
talking about [ __ ] vampires merch I
don't really re-watch a lot of our bits
because I I don't really re-watch our
show because we do it we're done that's
it the rehearsal Locker ones I actually
realized because I was howling because I
missed lines because we were laughing so
hard
it's a [ __ ] that's what I mean that
guy I need him I need him for all these
years please
I think let's just be team well it's
crazy blue origin big blue the Giants
like it's just kind of a marriage Maiden
in heaven I guess but yeah I went to the
first here's a question because Michael
why is it shape like a penis
yeah I mean it is a very penis shaped
rocket first launch and I and I watched
Jeff and his brothers
I have a question why is the rocket look
so delicious
that's right he can't figure out I can't
put my finger on it I've been banging
all these broads but it doesn't like
fill this like hole inside of me you
know I just want somebody to fill my
hole
do they make a smaller version of that
rocket or like a bigger version of a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
in heaven I guess but yeah I went to
this I wonder what like the really like
stuffy Rumble you know people that just
doesn't about politics think when they
tune into our show oh they hate us we've
seen the comments the mark and the other
crew members go up and I remember being
there thinking I'll never no way I would
ever do it it was the most amazing thing
I've ever seen outside of childbirth and
and it was I'm sorry
while childbirth is impressive going to
space is going to top that I understand
way more people have given birth than
have gone to space that's a good point
made you emotional to see it and it
completely changed my mind about why
yeah oh by the way I got a donation from
Zach luchikamia twenty twenty five
dollar tip thank you so much in the
locals chat if this is what the show is
going to be like starting December 1st I
can't wait go sign up on locals you
sister girl pores
if I would do it the reason we had a lot
of fun this is a preview you know when
they show your preview that this is
going to be every day now behind it why
other people want to do it and and then
I I pretty much a few months later or so
got a call saying do you want to go up
really and I had expressed to some
people that hey I was really and I said
go up where
I'm already in my penthouse I'm all on
the top floor
I would actually do that after seeing it
and apparently they heard it and they
called me and I stuck my foot too deep
in my mouth to pull it out
I mean what was the part that freaked
you out was that the launching or was it
the coming all of it was it like the
fact that you won't get like have any
booze or cocaine on the rocket for hours
oh God that's not at all I was I would
like how did you not get the shakes
yeah
I feel like Strahan's a guy that drinks
one glass of red wine with dinner that
he seems like that kind of guy right
like when things come out and legs come
out and it's yes yeah and then the
capsule like this okay I'm sorry we have
to go back because he's doing the thing
where he's acting like a child again
right his childlike wonderment here you
go the Michael Strahan I mean all of it
was really like when the rocket comes
back down it's like Iron Man this thing
come back and lands on the pad like when
things come out and legs come out and
it's yes
this is two kids talking about their
toys with each other yes they're making
the noises but you're making the noises
with your mouth
yeah and then the capsule like this
you're you're looking you're going okay
I'm going to see them floats yeah
[ __ ] human Foley Department Jimmy
Fallon can't help but do noises
Christ holy work yeah wow all right hey
man then they disappear
and then you go oh that's really high
wow and I was I had to fly I had to fly
you know uh the other day and I'm like
looking at the thing that tells you
you're 43 000 feet I'm going hey this is
way
way I love I can't
man this way up here we're real high in
the sky
I'm looking down on the clouds
I said myself whoa I'm upside down
okay so this is the same episode he
surprises fans at a madame two okay just
just watch
hey guys welcome back to the show
tonight we're visiting all five boroughs
in New York City right now we're in
Manhattan Hill why at the world famous
Madame Tussauds Wax Museum in Times
Square
wow that looks nothing like him yeah
Daniel you know what that you know what
that looks like a wax statue of Daniel
Craig he looks sad he looks so well
Daniel Craig he's so sick of doing Bond
movies
millions of people visit here every oh
my God
the ghost hi the Ghostbusters that they
put up no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
the Ghostbusters they put up
were the female ones oh [ __ ] this Museum
I'm gonna go in there with a
flamethrower
go in there just turn the heat all the
way up exactly it's gonna be Madame
Tussaud's [ __ ] puddle of wax
let's get some of those hot hands and
start sticking them in their pockets
yeah oh yeah the ones that you get in
the snow Yeah
merch is up there putting cigarettes out
on their tits while they melt through
what melts through
sir is that a space heater under your
T-shirt no
so you're under arrest you malt her face
with a nectar collector
doing this to them
[Laughter]
of their favorite celebrities and I want
to have a little fun with them and so
does my first guest you can see new
episodes of his document series more
than an athlete Thursdays on ESPN plus
no not because
Michael Strahan
[Laughter]
right to be fair I'm going to give him
credit
he was making a funny face like I'll
give Michael Strahan that he's not
someone I give I will give him this he
does not take himself seriously no it's
just like look at the face he's made
hold on look at this Christ he's [ __ ]
what an [ __ ] look at this face
[Laughter]
he's such a goofball he's a goofball
he's impossible to hate I I trying but I
can't hey buddy how you doing hey
everybody
Michael you and I have a lot in common
besides our our physiques yeah I'm
wearing your suit right uh we both yeah
you both shouldn't be on TV
they're both extremely lucky in
broadcasting you guys laugh way too much
when other people are talking
figures of ourselves especially Jimmy
Fallon oh yeah he but that guy broke all
the that guy took the Caribou net show
too seriously here at Madame Tussauds
and so I thought it'd be fun to pretend
to be our wax figures and then surprise
people I'm a best friend ready to do
this dude let's do it all right a wax
figure and a wacker okay
plant said finger
oh did it cut out my bad I'm sorry must
have cut out
foreign
Rumble rant wow whoa thank you so much
thank you that was a big boy money gleep
work because why not
oh we will be oh thanks we will be
splitting that and using it on
prostitutes well that's not gonna go
very far
I guess a tip for a nation's seriously
cover yeah it's about enough I've never
seen the back of my ear
now you made me look at the back of my
ear I've never seen it either oh my God
they even got the crooked finger wow
hey you ever help I think that was just
a mistake like I don't think they did
the crooked finger on purpose your own
hand with the same hand
okay folks this is Tim he's your
photographer today
you guys big Tonight Show fans
yeah that's your typical Tonight Show
fan that's about right right yeah
typical yeah especially tonight's show
like let's go to New York City and look
at the wax statues of people oh my God
they stand in line for tickets for SNL
yeah right yeah it's not like the same
as just going to see a show or something
right right the people that do the whole
tour
you don't think they just immediately
knows us for some reason no both of you
look very [ __ ] a lot like mannequins
so don't worry about both of you are
absolutely Fake Plastic people you'll be
fine you'll be you're gonna do great
just be yourself I think that we can get
away with it
all right here comes the next contestant
take a seat take a seat at the uh bench
yeah this looks great
you can set down your bags this would be
for me though
okay I will admit that is a good prank
it is right it's kind of corny it's a
hack prank but it's very it's good if
you have two famous people because
that's right right
well one famous person in Jimmy Fallon
but yeah that's true oh
Jimmy Fallon is probably still the
lowest rated out of all the Late Late
Night hosts which is weird right like
people rather watch [ __ ] Colbert